como seguro han observado en otros de
mis vídeos sólo hacer ejemplos
simplificados y con números enteros si
es posible pero es hora de tomar una
pequeña dosis de realidad y analizar una
transacción que realmente ocurrió para
ver que algunos de esos ceros se están
vendiendo por mucho menos de lo que las
personas pagaron por ellos o de lo que
está escrito en las hojas de balance
veremos cómo pueden incluso valer menos
que el precio al que los están vendiendo
actualmente con algunos trucos
analicemos este texto y después puedes
sacar tus propias conclusiones este
texto es la traducción al español de una
parte del comunicado de prensa que dio
merrill lynch el 28 de julio del 2008 y
hay que recordar que acababan de
reportar sus ganancias el 30 de junio o
sea acababan de tomar las fotos muy
bonitas a sus hojas de balance y
publicarlas por todos lados eso es algo
que hay que tomar en cuenta
el texto dice que el 28 de junio del
merrill lynch aceptó vender una cantidad
de 30.6 millones de dólares
estadounidenses nacional bruto super
senior a bs cedemos a un afiliado de
lone star funds a un precio de 6 puntos
7 billones de dólares y que son esos 30
puntos 7 billones de dólares
estadounidenses nacional bruto eso es
que merrill lynch pagó por ellos 30
puntos 6 billones de dólares o que el
valor original de esos dedos era 30
puntos 6 billones de dólares así es que
30 puntos 6 billones de dólares de
nacional bruto nacional
tengo la noción de que eso vale esta
cosa y eso es súper senior abs de osh
eso suena muy seguro super cinia es los
que tienen prioridad siempre y abs es la
abreviación en inglés de asset backed
securities y en español sería título con
garantía en una
los activos en este caso son los videos
o sea suena súper seguro no sólo es su
principio sino que además tiene garantía
en un activo los activos en este caso
son los dedos lo cual ya empiezan a
sonar también verdad
ahora sabemos mucho de estos dedos de
estas obligaciones de deuda
colateralizada y se los están vendiendo
a un afiliado del long stars fund que es
una firma de capital privado de texas
les voy a subrayar en verde porque ellos
sí saben lo que están haciendo se los
están vendiendo a un precio de 6.7
billones de dólares a ver simplemente en
estas primeras líneas y de forma muy
superficial antes de que analicemos más
profundamente la situación notemos que
en algún momento hubo un activo este
activo del cual se tenía la noción o al
menos alguien tenía la noción de que ese
activo valía 30 puntos 6 billones de
dólares y ahora están vendiendo ese
activo a esta firma de capital privado
por unos 6 puntos 7 millones de dólares
recordemos que un millón de dólares en
el sentido estadounidense equivale a mil
millones de dólares
en cambio en muchos otros lugares como
méxico o muchos lugares de habla hispana
un millón de dólares equivale a
un millón de millones de dólares y en
este vídeo vamos a seguir esa notación
entonces cuál es la recuperación de ese
activo superficialmente más adelante
vamos a ver cómo la recuperación sobre
ese activo es incluso peor de lo que
parece lo están vendiendo a 6.7 billones
de dólares y es un activo que
originalmente creían que valía 30 puntos
6 billones entonces para sacar la
recuperación vamos a dividir 6.7
millones entre 30 puntos 6 billones que
originalmente creían que valían y nos da
punto 22.22 de recuperación o sea están
pagando 22 centavos por cada dólar
entonces al menos lo que la primera
oración implica es que están obteniendo
punto 22 por cada dólar 22 centavos por
cada dólar con respecto al valor
original de estos activos
al final del segundo trimestre del 2008
y notemos que el final del segundo
trimestre del 2008 es cuatro semanas
antes de la publicación de este
comunicado de prensa
el final del segundo trimestre es el 30
de junio o sea 4 semanas antes del 28 de
julio del 2008 observa nada más lo que
puede pasar en cuatro semanas al final
del segundo trimestre del 2008
esto sucede o se evaluaban a 11.1
billones de dólares
así es que en la hoja de balance de
merrill lynch en algún punto
probablemente el año pasado decía que
estos activos valían 30 puntos 6
billones ellos también se dieron cuenta
de que estos activos eran apestosos y
para hacer o al menos aparentar ser
sinceros tuvieron que bajar un poco su
valor en sus hojas de balance a 11.1
billones y bueno no quieren bajar su
valor demasiado porque si lo hacen nadie
va a querer invertir en merrill lynch y
tal vez van a empezar a decir que
merrill lynch ya no vale nada entonces
en algún punto dijeron sabes qué vamos a
hacer se hubo honestos con el mercado y
estas cosas que antes valían 30 puntos 6
billones vamos a escribir
11.1 millones en los libros y no sé
cuánto tiempo se tardaron en darse
cuenta que esté activo de 30.6 billones
en realidad sólo valía 11.1 millones yo
no sé cuánto tiempo se tardaron en darse
cuenta de que este activo de 30 puntos 6
billones actualmente solo vale
11.1 billones pero en ese momento
hicieron una rebaja de cuantos billones
de 19.5 billones y lo hicieron para
aparentar ser pseudo honestos pero lo
evaluaron en 11.1 millones y después
cuatro semanas después lo vendieron en
6.7 billones de dólares
así es que cuánto pudieron recuperar por
este activo les están dando 6 puntos 7
billones de dólares por un activo que
apenas hace cuatro semanas y no mucho
puede pasar en cuatro semanas decían que
valía 11.1 billones de dólares
veamos cuánto pueden recuperar del
activo por dólar
6.7 qué es lo que están obteniendo entre
11.1 que es lo que creían que valía osea
punto 60 punto 60 así es que están
obteniendo 60 centavos por cada dólar
con respecto a lo que decían que valía
el activo el 30 de junio cierto o sea es
una recuperación del 60 por ciento con
respecto a lo que ellos creían que
tenían hace cuatro semanas y ellos dicen
con respecto a esta venta merrill lynch
realizará una rebaja de 4.4 billones
están rebajando 4.4 billones y porque
4.4 es la resta de lo que ellos creían o
decían que valía osea 11.1 billones de
dólares
menos lo que terminó valiendo la activo
o sea 6 puntos 7 billones lo más
interesante del asunto es que las malas
noticias no terminan aquí puedes decir
que son muy malas noticias sólo
obtuvieron 22 centavos por dólar de algo
que originalmente creían
30 puntos 6 billones y que además apenas
hace cuatro semanas creían que valía
11.1 millones honestamente yo no creo
que hayan obtenido más información
importante estas últimas cuatro semanas
yo creo que el 30 de junio hicieron la
rebaja a 11.1 billones sólo porque les
convenía ese número es una rebaja
suficientemente grande como para que
parezca que están siendo honestos pero
no es demasiado grande como para que las
personas se asusten mucho esta es la
parte realmente interesante aquí quité
un pedazo de la traducción del
comunicado de prensa que habla un poco
acerca de la exposición nos podríamos
meter a analizarlo pero me está daría
fácil otros 20 minutos así es que mejor
vamos a este otro párrafo importantísimo
que estaba escondido en el medio del
comunicado de prensa
y el verdadero meollo del asunto y yo
espero que te dé una idea de los trucos
sucios que hace la industria financiera
para esconder la información a las
personas
merrill lynch proporcionará
financiamiento al comprador por
aproximadamente 75 por ciento del precio
de la compra o sea lonestar fons está
comprando estos deseos por 6.7 millones
pero el 75% del dinero es un préstamo de
merrill lynch cuánto dinero le está
prestando
son 6 puntos 7 a lo que están vendiendo
y les están prestando el 75 por ciento o
sea les están prestando aproximadamente
5 billones merrill lynch les está
prestando aproximadamente 5 billones eso
no está nada bueno lone star está
diciendo estos activos son tan apestosos
que solo estamos dispuestos a pagar 6
puntos 7 billones de dólares
bueno de hecho ni siquiera estamos
dispuestos a pagar con nuestro dinero tú
vas a tener que prestarle la mayor parte
del dinero que voy a usar para comprar
este activo y eso no estaría tan mal si
le prestará ese dinero al estar de una
forma normal si fuera un préstamo normal
al onstar
lo más probable es que eventualmente
recuperaría su dinero y si por algún
motivo lo estar no le quisiera o pudiera
pagar y ese activo no valiera nada
podrían hacer que pagará su deuda
reclamando la propiedad de los otros
activos de loustau si los activos de los
estar en general avalan el préstamo
entonces tal vez no es una idea tan
a prestarles ese dinero porque le gusta
muy probablemente tiene un montón de
activos la verdad la verdad no sé pero
yo sospecho que es una firma de capital
muy grande y lo que sigue es un
verdadero insulto el aval sobre este
préstamo el aval es lo que tú puedes
reclamar como tuyo si la otra persona
decide que no quiere pagar o resulta que
no puede pagar un préstamo que le diste
el aval sobre este préstamo será
limitado a los activos del comprador el
comprador no será dueño de ningún otro
activo salvo aquellos vendidos en esta
transacción así es que lo que lo estará
hizo porque lo gustar si tiene un montón
de activos aparte del que está comprando
en esta transacción estoy casi segura de
ello fue crear una corporación que no
tiene absolutamente nada y así si no
pagan la deuda no pierden nada más así
es que este afiliado es creado por lone
star lonestar le da 1.7 billones los
cuales conforman todo su capital
merrill lynch le presta a este afiliado
y entonces el afiliado le compra a merry
lynch con esos 5 billones más el 1.7 o
también podríamos decir que merrill
lynch logra deshacerse de estos tebeos
apestosos por 6 puntos 7 billones entre
comillas por el préstamo de los 5
billones y yo juraría que esta
corporación fue creada especialmente
para esta transacción y su razón de
existir es muy específica fue creada
para que merrill lynch quitara sus
libros estos cebos apestosos sin que
parezca en ellos que los remató a ver
qué es lo que realmente está pasando
digamos que estos dedos valen cero
digamos que no valen nada
en el vídeo pasado vimos por qué podría
hacer es el caso y bueno en este caso
que es lo que pierde lo estar bueno
ellos no tienen que pagar esos cinco
billones aquí dice el comprador no será
dueño de ningún otro activo salvo
aquellos vendidos en esta transacción y
además también dice el aval sobre este
préstamo será limitado
a los activos del comprador así es que
si ellos no pagan el préstamo lo único
que puede hacer merrill lynch es
recuperar esos deseos que ahora no valen
nada y entonces qué pasa pues lo start
habrá perdido únicamente los 1.7
billones que le pagó originalmente a
merry lynch ahora qué pasa si por
ejemplo esos cede os valen 2 billones de
dólares pues lone star no va a querer
pagar 5 billones para poder quedarse con
esos tebeos que ahora valen 2 billones
nada más no es un buen trato entonces lo
que va a pasar es que no van a pagar el
préstamo de 5 billones y merrill lynch
se va a quedar con los 1.7 billones que
le dio originalmente lo está y va a
recuperar sus tebeos así es que
podríamos decir que los start está
arriesgando 1.7 billones y si resulta
que los tebeos valen más de 5 billones
entonces lo está se va a quedar con el
exceso
a ver creo que hay una mejor forma de
explicar esto este va a ser el precio de
los cds ok y hay varias barreras
importantes si los tebeos valen 5
billones si valen 6 puntos 7 billones o
si valen 0 billones si los tebeos valen
entre 5 y 0 billones entonces al no
estar no le conviene pagar el préstamo o
sea no le conviene pagar 5 billones para
quedarse con algo que vale menos de 5
billones
entonces lo estar va a perder los 1.7
billones que le dio originalmente
merrill lynch y merrill lynch pues se va
a quedar con esos 1.7 billones más
sucede o es que le van a regresar porque
nos van a pagar el préstamo ahora si el
precio de los cds está entre 6.7 y 5
entonces al honesta le conviene pagar el
préstamo para quedarse con los tebeos no
va a recuperar sus 1.7 billones que le
dio a merrill lynch porque va a usar 5
billones para
pagar el préstamo y quedarse con los
dedos y va a recuperar pues nada más un
pedacito por acá que es menor a 1.7
billones ahora si el precio de los
deseos es mayor a 6.7 entonces lo está
definitivamente va a pagar el préstamo
para quedarse con ellos porque no sólo
va a recuperar su inversión original
sino que va a ganar la diferencia entre
el valor de los deseos y 6.7 va a ganar
el exceso del valor de los deseos sobre
el 6.7 si en los libros de merrill lynch
estaba en lo correcto y no se devaluaron
los deseos y actualmente valen 11.1
millones de dólares entonces long start
songs habrá ganado 4.4 billones de
dólares con esta transacción por otro
lado si eso sucede os valen actualmente
7 billones de dólares entonces lo un
start recuperará sus 1.7 billones de
dólares
ganará con esta transacción otros puntos
3 billones de dólares no mucho pero algo
es algo
entonces las ganancias del onstar pueden
variar entre perder 1.7 billones de
dólares hasta ganar bueno no hay ninguna
cuota superior con respecto a cuánto
pueden ganar pero honestamente no creo
que sucede os valgan más de 11.1
millones de dólares y al final de
cuentas sólo está arriesgando 1.7
billones de dólares y bueno aquí merrill
lynch tiene la ventaja de que aunque
estos cds valgan 0 va a recuperar por lo
menos 1.7 billones y entonces podemos
calcular que es lo mínimo que va a
recuperar
por lo menos va a recuperar 1.7 / haber
hay que hacerlo con respecto a las dos
por ejemplo con respecto a su valor
original su valor nacional original d
30.6 millones o sea punto 06 ok entonces
por lo menos por lo menos va a recuperar
punto 0 6 de su valor nacional bruto
original ahora con respecto al valor que
estimaban de él hace cuatro semanas
a ver les van a pagar 1.7
entre el cuánto creían que valía hace
cuatro semanas se apuntó 15
entonces lo mínimo que va a recuperar
merrill lynch son 6 centavos por dólar
con respecto a el valor nacional
original del activo o 15 centavos por
dólar con respecto a lo que merrill
lynch creía que valía su activo hace 4
semanas
bueno creía o decía que valía ok eso es
lo mínimo que va a recuperar merrill
lynch eso es lo que pasa si los fideos
valen 0 ok ahora como máximo lo máximo
que puede obtener merrill lynch son esos
6 puntos 7 millones de dólares 1.7 que
pagó lonestar al inicio y 5 billones de
dólares si el valor de los cedros es
mayor que 5 millones y por lo tanto lo
start si quiere pagar su préstamo en fin
este fue un ejemplo de la vida real no
lo inventé yo y espero que te dé una muy
buena idea de cómo son las cosas en el
mundo real